good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight queen elizabeth ii died
today in scotland as you likely know at
the age of 96 she was the
longest-serving monarch in british
history she was born in one world and
died in another
it's not easy to maintain your dignity
while living in the public eye most of
us could not pull it off for an
afternoon queen elizabeth did it for
more than 70 years i want to ask you all
she wrote shortly before her coronation
in 1953 whatever your religion may be to
pray for me on that day to pray that god
may give me wisdom and strength to carry
out the solemn promises i shall be
making and that i may faithfully serve
him and you
all the days of my life
for the most part she did just that and
that was not a small achievement given
the period she lived in
the week that elizabeth was coronated
edmund hillary a british subject from
new zealand a beekeeper became the first
man in history to summon mount everest
the achievement seemed symbolic at the
time britain on top of the world
but in fact britain was already over
whether the british knew it or not
to this day britain claims to have won
both of the 20th century's world wars
but together they destroyed that nation
forever after victory came humiliation
the empire evaporated and along with it
britain's self-confidence and ultimately
its self-respect it's hard to believe
now but britain wasn't always a regional
banking center refugee camp it was a
real place with a history and a language
and a culture and a genuinely remarkable
people
a country in the north atlantic the size
of alabama that somehow took over the
world
and ruled it with decency unmatched by
any empire in human history
the british empire was not perfect but
it was far more humane than any other
ever
it's gone now barely even remembered
queen elizabeth ii was the last living
link to a truly great britain
today on social media the usual ghouls
celebrated her death quote may her pain
be excruciating a carnegie mellon
professor called ujoo anya wrote on
twitter of the queen may she die in
agony
various know-nothings the media
including a columnist at the atlantic
and a couple of employees of nbc news
seconded that thought
the british empire was evil they wrote
apparently totally unaware of what came
after it and speaking of what did come
after the british empire how for example
did africa fare after the british left
let's see
uganda got idi amin who was a cannibal
rhodesia became zimbabwe and then became
the poorest country on the planet under
the racist lunatic robert mugabe as of
tonight south africa is still being run
into the ground by an incompetent
kleptocrat called cyril ramiposa
so it's hard to see any of that as an
improvement because it's not an
improvement sorry atlantic magazine
and now of course the entire continent
of africa has a new master the chinese
government china is the latest colonial
power to dominate africa
its subjects will be pining for the
british soon assuming they are not
already
in an ideal world there would not be
empires no empires only sovereign
nations but we don't have that world and
we never have had that world going back
to at least the assyrians 1400 years
before christ in the real world the one
that we live in strong countries
dominate weak countries and that trend
shows no sign of changing
the very least you can say about the
english is that they took their colonial
responsibilities seriously they didn't
just take things they added
when the us government withdrew from
afghanistan after 20 years we left
behind airstrips shipping containers and
guns
when the british pulled out of india
they left behind an entire civilization
a language a legal system schools
churches and public buildings all of
which are still in use today
here's the train station the english
built in bombay for example there's
nothing like that in washington dc right
now much less in kabul or baghdad today
india is far more powerful than the uk
the nation that once ruled it and yet
after 75 years of independence has that
country produced a single building as
beautiful as the bombay train station
that the british colonialists built no
sadly it has not not one
so despite what they may be claiming on
twitter tonight the british empire was
more than just genocide in fact the
british did not commit genocide except
arguably against the dutch during the
boer war
the british did give the world the magna
carta and habeas corpus and free speech
they helped end the transatlantic slave
trade as well as the ritual murder of
widows in india
the british empire spread protestant
christianity to the entire world it
published some of the greatest
literature ever written and produced the
finest manufactured goods ever made
anywhere at any time including now
it was an impressive place run by
impressive people
we will see many empires going forward
but we will never see one so benign
that's true
and because it's true the people who
would like to run the world in a far
harsher way would like to make certain
that you don't know it
and so they destroy the evidence the
evidence that ever existed here they are
tearing down a statue of a british
philanthropist in the uk two years ago
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
destroy the statue
erase the memory that's why they're
doing it slander the ruler discredit the
entire period she lived in and that's
exactly why they're attacking queen
elizabeth tonight
not because she was a bad person she
wasn't a bad person but because she
lived during a better time
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight